perhaps the finest way to develop a
loving attitude towards other people is
to recall in the face of their
difficulty that we are in the end all
children
the claim is an odd one
adults are clearly not children
they have powers of reasoning that quite
outstrip those of younger people
they have options and a sound grasp of
right and wrong
they are capable of causing serious
damage
they should know better
children on the other hand are well
known for their powers to melt our
hearts
partly this has to do with their
physical appearance
with their unusually large eyes their
full cheeks
their unthreatening statures
their tiny fat fleshy fingers
but ultimately the child attracts our
tenderness because when they act in bad
or tricky ways
it tends to be easy to work out why they
have done so
they hit their little sister because
they were feeling left out
they started to steal things from other
children because their parents were
going through a divorce
they ran away from the party without
saying goodbye
because they were panicked by a sense of
unworthiness
overall when it comes to the psychology
of children we discover a surprising and
hugely gentle truth
that badness and difficulty
are invariably the result of some form
of pain discomfort hurt or wound
the child does not start by being
dreadful they become so in response to
injury fear or sorrow
with adults on the other hand confronted
by nasty or terrible behavior
our thoughts do not for understandable
reasons
generally turn to imagining why it might
have occurred
we're satisfied with nimble and
compressed reasons because they're an
[ __ ]
because they're crazy
this will do for now
and yet it is always open to us to
wonder why someone acted as they did
and here we are liable to stumble on an
always provocative and properly
revolutionary idea
the reason why little children and big
people do wrong
is despite the differences in age and
size
exactly the same
one category may be no bigger than a
chair
the other can be gigantic
and able to carry guns
post lengthy screeds online
or start and bankrupt companies
but in the end the psychology of blunder
meanness and anger
is always the same
evil is a consequence of injury
the big person did not start off evil
their difficult sides were not hardwired
from the start
they grew towards malice on account of
some form of wound waiting to be
discovered
it is the work of extraordinary patience
and humanity
it is the work of love
to go in search of what these wounds
might be
to search is morally frightening
because we too easily imagine that it
might require us to wind up thinking
well of behaviour we know is abhorrent
it doesn't at all
we can remain appalled while
simultaneously tracing a path
back to the true catalytic factors
the work can also be practically
frightening because we imagine that it
might require us to leave someone at
liberty to cause us and others more pain
but again we can keep the wrongdoer
safely behind very high bars
even as we sensitively explore the
origins of their violations
once the full stories of our trespasses
become known our perspective may swiftly
rework itself
the bully who pursued us online
had once worked as a porter
then been fired some years back and
fallen into depression and was facing
the bankruptcy courts
the angry populist politician was
remorselessly belittled by a powerful
father
the sexually impulsive person
used their addiction to calm themselves
down from some unmasterable anxieties
related to early emotional neglect
our judgment on behaviour never has to
change
our sense of why it occurred can be
transformed
the discipline of psychotherapy has been
central in helping us to chart the
sometimes unobvious or contrary
connections between a symptom and its
genesis
boastfulness may have its roots in fear
anger can mask terror
hatred can be a defense against love
the haughty heir of the grown-up can
take hold as a way of compensating for
invisibility
a satirical manner can be a shield
against an exiled longing for sweetness
the prison system in most countries
tends to place people below the age of
18 in separate young offenders
institutions
which treat inmates with a degree of
kindness and hope
in order to delve into the psychology of
transgression with a view to
understanding and overcoming its causes
but after this age for the most part
prisoners are locked up in bare cells
and the key is metaphorically thrown
away
they should after all have known better
and yet we are all as it were young
offenders
however old we might actually be
in other words we all need our crimes to
be treated with a degree of sympathy and
empathetic investigation
it is an exquisite feat of mind to be
able to imagine them as always still at
some level
infants in a cradle
connect is a card game to foster
connection and closeness with 100
questions that help couples to rekindle
affection
you